The tragedy about Pakistan,
you see,
at least,
this is what I say in my book,
is that in many ways both democratic or
I'd prefer to say civilian government
and military governments have failed to
develop the country,
have both failed to create a more just
and equitable system.
I mean the most successful as far as
economic development was concerned was
admittedly a military government that
evaluate.
But since then,
um,
Musharraf seemed to be doing quite well
in that regard.
But much of the growth under Musharraf
turned out,
unfortunately,
to be fairly empty,
it was a consumer boom more than
anything else.
And the key reason for that is that new
government has been strong enough
because the state itself is not strong
enough to change the fundamentals of the
society,
the domination of kingship,
the domination of what are called in
Pakistan,
feudals the intensely conservative
nature of much of society.
The lack of education,
the prejudice against education,
the lack of women's education in
particular,
the extremely high birth rate,
which tends to swamp every attempt to
increase services.
Uh,
so it's not just the civilian
governments have failed a military.
Governments have also failed,
unfortunately,
that's on the other hand and this I
think also needs to be brought out very
strongly.
Uh,
they haven't failed completely.
The country has stuck together or least
the west of it as the east breakaway,
uh,
and I think it will continue to stick
together.
And after all,
that's quite something given the
neighborhood in which it finds itself
and the internal strains that it faces
government,
which the Americans are keeping in power
in Pakistan is one of the most Venal and
corrupt governments.
We've had these learned nothing from the
last time his gang were in bar.
I mean,
corruption really does ground that
country from the top.
That's where the fishes Rockman the head
and then it seeps downwards.
So in order to preserve,
and this,
he does whatever the U s asks him.
The big joke is whether Pakistan
ambassador to the United States who's
regarded as a well known us agent for
the last 25 years,
shouldn't more appropriately be the US
ambassador to Pakistan.
And these are the questions people ask
and,
and talk about all the time.
I want to introduce a new political
culture,
democratic culture,
and one of the elements is that I cannot
put myself as the president,
so I would much prefer that I'm going to
join the apm as a member and when the
membership drive is there and when we
form a counsel,
let them elect me and tell me whether
they want me as president,
so therefore I'm going on the part that
I will be a member of the PML.
Let us see.
Then what happens.